muestra todos los valores positivos de
penn para los cuales la serie
convergente y tenemos esta serie de aquí
en la suma desde en igual a 1 hasta
infinito de menos 1 elevado a la n 1 que
multiplican ap / 6 elevado a la n ahora
hay varias cosas por aquí que debes de
notar en primer lugar tengo este menos 1
elevado a la n 1 y sin n va de 1 a 2 a 3
a 4 esté menos 1 elevado a la n 1 lo que
va a hacer es alternar se entre menos
uno y uno menos uno y uno entonces vamos
a tener que los signos se alternan y
esto va a ser la clave para que
lleguemos a la respuesta es más vamos a
escribirlo esto va a ser igual a 100 es
igual a 1 me queda esto elevado al
cuadrado entonces sería positivo y aquí
me quedarían pm entre 6 elevado a la
primera potencia de entre 6 elevado a la
primera potencia ahora si n vale 2
aquí me queda el cubo entonces sería
p / 6 elevado a la segunda potencia ok y
si n vale 3
esto es par por lo tanto me quedara
positivo positivo y después me quedan p
entre 6 elevado a la tercera potencia
sin n vale 4 esto es impar entonces me
quedan signo negativo y me quedarían p
entre 6 esto elevado a la cuarta
potencia y así nos vamos a mantener
sumando y restando etcétera así para
siempre así que claramente esto sería
una clásica serie que se va alternando y
con esto podemos aplicar el criterio de
la serie alternante y el criterio de las
series alternantes nos dice lo siguiente
primero observamos la parte que no
alterna que es esta parte de acá
si esta parte de acá cumple dos
condiciones déjame ponerlo aquí sí
entre 6 y elevado a la en la parte que
no alterna cumple que es en primer lugar
que es monótona mente decreciente
monótonamente decreciente que
esencialmente es una forma elegante de
decir que cada término consecutivo es
menor que la anterior y por otra parte
el límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
la parte que no alternando pp entre 6
elevado a la n esto es igual a cero si
cumple estas dos condiciones entonces la
serie converge
así que bajo qué condiciones estas dos
eran ciertas bueno para cumplir ambas
condiciones pe / 6 tiene que ser menor
que 1 porque si pe entre 6 fuera igual a
1 entonces esto no sería monótonamente
decreciente porque cada término sería 11
ha elevado a la primera potencia menos 1
elevado al cuadrado más uno elevado al
cubo etcétera y si fuera mayor que 6
entonces cada vez que multiplicamos por
p entre 6 obtendremos un número más
grande tendremos un número uno más
grande uno más más grande uno más más
más más grande y después otro y otro y
otro y por lo tanto el límite tenlo por
seguro que no sería igual a cero
entonces en definitiva tenemos que decir
que p entre 6 tiene que ser menor que 1
o dicho otra manera tiene que ser menor
que 6 para que esto ocurra y además nos
dicen que mostremos todos los valores
positivos de p
por lo tanto pp en definitiva tiene que
ser mayor que 0 entonces mayor que 0 y
menor que 6 es justa esta opción que
tengo aquí esta es mi opción correcta
y acabamos observa no puede ser igual a
6 recuerda porque si p es menor o igual
a 6 en el caso en el que sea igual
entonces de nuevo tendremos que esta
serie cada término sería uno elevado a
la n y entonces tendríamos uno en menos
uno más uno menos uno etcétera y así
para siempre entonces esta es mi
respuesta correcta